hey youtubers what's up this is gonna be
my last airbender episode 1 & 2 video
they're really designed to be aired
back-to-back so I'm just going to
include both of those in this one video
hello any new people - if you're just
finding me for the first time I'm
rewatching all of last airbender and
doing videos just like I did for Korra
so I will start by saying general
spoiler warning but these videos will
mostly go like the way I do my other
core videos I'm also continuing the
weekly giveaway which I'll totally
explain at the end of this video it
might sound a little weird but I'll just
say spoiler warning just in case you
haven't seen the first two episodes I
mean they're priceless some people out
there that haven't seen avatar yet so
starting with top five moments number
five Katara's intro sequence so I'm
actually one of the people that only
found the series after it aired on TV so
by the time I did see it I already knew
who may Whitman was she'd already done
Johnny Bravo and a whole bunch of other
voice work she's just got one of those
voices that's so much fun to listen to
she's actually the voice of April and
Neil on Ninja Turtles right now for
anyone who's a fan of that series that's
just another Nickelodeon cartoon the
intro sequence itself is this huge
calling card for the series in general
so much so that they kept it whenever
they produce Legend of Korra it's one of
my favorite things about the series in
general I don't tolerate long intro
sequences especially in the era of the
Netflix marathon watch but the avatar
intro sequence and Legend of Korra after
it just so much fun like done so well
the music score is great I could listen
to that all day it works beautifully as
an explainer for people who have never
seen the series before this intro
sequence the one for episode 1 is extra
long just because it's the first episode
anyone ever saw so they they have to
explain a lot of extra stuff it just it
sets up the hundred year war and the
complete prehistory of the show so they
don't have to spend a couple episodes
explaining what's going on if you saw
the 15 minute unaired pilot they
actually deal with some story in that
that they include in the intro sequence
mostly hundred year war Fire Nation
stuff number for keeping your weirdness
to yourself and n gets unfrozen I like
the way Mike and Bryan connect the idea
of expressing yourself as being like a
really good thing
with bringing the avatar back into the
world think about it this way if Katara
had listened to Sokka suppressed her
bending you know kept it inside not told
anyone about it not practiced that
there's a good chance any would have
stayed frozen in that giant block ice
team break is just trying to communicate
that being creative putting yourself out
there is a
you know don't listen to trolls don't
listen to haters I like the idea of
Sakai being the original avatar internet
troll eventually he did chill out though
it just I think that at this time in the
series in his head space he's trying to
deal with being the new man of the house
after their parents died
even though guitars clearly the brains
of the operation then you have just like
the visual action set piece of egg
returning that was the first big action
set piece of the series no matter how
many times I rewatched the episode I'm
always amazed at how quickly he just
jumps into casual conversation like it's
absolutely no big deal that he just
walked out of a block of ice I think
they did it that way just because they
wanted to start the series off on a
positive note just to get you more
excited for the hero just to get you
more excited about Aang if you really
think about it the circumstances that
put him in the ice it's a little
inconsistent he ran away after they told
him he was going to be the new avatar
flew into a storm then passed out as he
and Appa hit the water so he should have
been super scared when he woke up the
natural reaction after being at frozen
would be like screaming in terror
because you're still locked into that
moment when you first got frozen let's
just call that like a general you know
hand waving TV Logic moment you know
they just did not want to start the
series off on a bummer moment having
their hero scream and terror and freak
like little kids out everywhere on to
number three
Zucco's introduction so I wasn't a big
fan of Zuko and book 1 just because Mike
and Bryan did their job so well you're
not supposed to like Zuko he's the
antagonist to book one even Iroh is like
dude chill out seriously have some tea
we're on an extended vacation just have
fun you guys can let me know if you
agree but don't you feel like when a
villain complaints too much or gets
casually dismissed by other villains
like Zuko in this scene you
automatically stop thinking of him as an
insurmountable threat like he's still
threat at this point in the series you
know he's not quite as good a bender as
Azula but he's still really good little
quirks like this feel totally normal
inside children shows it's just it's
like the producers want kids to be
afraid without thinking that things are
completely hopeless that actually that
comes later hopelessness comes at the
end of book 2 in the Crystal Caves with
that finale Last Airbender was a very
mature series for being such a
children's show but I think they just
wanted to ease into that on to number
two Zuko versus the Water Tribe I'm
surprised Sokka didn't paint his face
more often in later episodes like
whenever they knew they were walking
into battles he looks pretty badass with
it on and the standoff with Zuko was a
great hero moment for him I think it was
a lot easier to give Sokka big moments
like this before Toph came along it's
like you know Justice League before
Superman and Batman get there once they
show up it's just like so much harder to
stand out in a crowd that's like a whole
other conversation non-benders versus
bender heroes non-benders can still
totally had these big hero moments Asami
is a good example that she's still
badass but when they stand next to a Gor
Korra while they're in the Avatar State
doing something just superhuman it's
like they have to sacrifice their lives
in order to stand out in order for their
moment to have equal dramatic weight so
that's the formula if you're standing
next to the avatar and you want to seem
like a hero you just hasn't sacrificed
your life just a small price to pay and
my number 1 moment aang escapes with
Katara and Sokka this is the official
beginning of team avatar is they ride
off into the sunset and plot out the
rest of the series here this is what
we're going to be doing in the next 7
episodes it's also the first big egg
versus Zuko fight in the second big
Avatar State moment I mean technically
he was in the Avatar state when he
emerged from the ice Brian and Mike said
that one of the big aspects of the
series that Nickelodeon asked for
specifically was action without violence
so that's where the idea of bending
elements came in so everyone just wasn't
stabbing slicing or sawing each other in
half
bloodless action so this is like our
first big bloodless fight aren't you
curious though don't you just think with
all that firebending that more people
would be turned into crispy chickens
it's like if you think about it
logically it's like fire burns so hot
that everyone's skin would just get
cooked with the exception of firebenders
here's my big question for you guys
though what was your favorite moment
from the first two episodes and at this
point in the series what did you think
about all the characters before you'd
seen the other episodes before you knew
anything else about them so I want to
try something new with my avatar
episodes instead of giving them a rating
like I normally would I'm gonna do
thumbs up thumbs down so what I might
actually end up doing is like top 5
thumbs up top 5 thumbs down from now on
that just sounds like a fun idea so
thumbs down for what I'm not gonna be
too hard on the way that characters
reacted to situations or the voice
actors just since this is a series made
for children and perform mostly by
children my only thumbs down
are the lack of complexity in the minor
characters like that you know the really
minor characters like the Water Tribe
crowd scenes for instance in the
inconsistency in sokka's character it
just it feels like sokka's undiagnosed
bipolar at this point in the series he's
like a catch-all reaction jiff for every
twist in the plot so I totally
understand the role that he serves
that's actually that's why I think that
he over emotes so much and jumps from
really happy to really depressed in the
span of a few minutes I don't think it's
completely necessary but it's a cartoon
inspired by anime so I feel like these
scenes are them doing their version of
hyperbolic anime reactions whenever they
get to Korra though like by the time
they get to Korra the execution on those
types of moments were way better like
the visual gags I think that more has to
do with the overseas animation if you've
ever listened to the audio commentaries
on Korra DVDs Bryan and Mike talked a
lot about the visual things that they
wanted to accomplish on Last Airbender
that they just weren't able to achieve
like they just weren't able to get no
matter what they asked for but by the
time they got to Legend of Korra Studio
Mir different animation studio than from
The Last Airbender series was was
totally able to pull off the stuff they
asked for it still looks beautiful but I
think it was designed more for Western
audience so that's why Korra looks a
little more animate I think that was
probably their original intention with
last airbender but because it was their
first show with Nickelodeon they wanted
to do something that would fit better
with Nickelodeon's other programming so
what I'm probably gonna do is post my
next avatar video and the next like
seven or eight days I'll try and do one
at least once a week and just to explain
the weekly giveaway it's going to be a
$20 Amazon gift card just once a week in
case you're finding me for the first
time all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner my violet tears please
message me on my channel for details
thank you so much in case you guys
haven't seen just because a whole lot of
TV shows are coming back in the next
couple weeks like arrow flash Game of
Thrones
everything else I'll be posting a lot
more trailer videos than usual in the
next week or two so look out for that
stuff there's a lot of exciting stuff
coming I'm pretty good about posting my
schedule date today on Twitter and
Facebook so if you have questions about
what videos are going up on what days
just check my Twitter and Facebook feed
right now while you guys wait for my
next video you can click here to learn
all about the origins of the avatar
series behind the scenes like before
they actually made last airbender and
click here for all my other core videos
thank you so much watching so that's all
five I'll see you guys tonight
you